troops with us in Cincinnati I drew how
are you I'm good mr. Ramsey about
yourself better than I deserve what's up
well I've got a question I've been
married about two years income was about
seventy thousand stay at home wife and I
have no debt set for a mortgage I had no
experience with investments my my
mortgage that I was one hundred eleven
thousand
my wife and I both have a total about 30
grand savings
I don't know much follow your steps
they're supposed to do I heard about
snowballing and knock on the small debt
but my only that is that mortgage so am
I supposed to be packing that as much as
I possibly can to get that and not
investing where should I be looking to
invest on the side at the same time that
I'm attacking my mortgage cool question
drew I'll send you a copy of the book
the Total Money Makeover which has in it
a detailed explanation of all the seven
baby steps and exactly why we do them
when to do them where to do them and all
that kind of stuff but here's the basics
all right the basics are there seven
baby steps and you do them in order baby
step one is you save a thousand dollars
as a beginner starter emergency fund I'm
guessing you got a thousand bucks in the
bank yes sir
so you did that one check okay baby step
two debt-free accept the house check you
did that right yes sir baby step three a
fully funded grandma's rainy day fund
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses never to be touched except in
extreme emergencies and so three to six
months of expenses in a $70,000 income
house that's between ten and twenty
thousand dollars set aside do you have
that much saved in the bank yes sir okay
how much do you have in the bank thirty
thousand good for you all right well
earmark maybe 20 or whatever you want to
make your emergency fund fifteen or
twenty whatever you want to be
let's earmark that amount as your
emergency fund and maybe even set it in
a SEP
account so you don't accidentally buy
something with it okay
is that's not to be touched except for
an emergency that's a pad so if Murphy
comes up in life punches you in the face
you've got some money to catch the slack
you follow me yes sir okay then once
you've done that those are the basic
things that lays the foundation of your
house you've already done a great job
you're way ahead of the typical people
all right so now then the next steps
baby steps three four five and six we do
simultaneously four is what you were
asking about we start saving 15% of your
income into Roth IRAs and 401ks or
whatever you've got available to you
into good growth stock mutual funds and
then baby step five while you're doing
that we fund kids college you have
children yes sir have you saved anything
for their school yet yes how much just a
couple thousands and kind of good how
old are the kids seven just one perfect
well let's just sit down and with a good
investment advisor to someone to help
you put the mutual funds in place and
let's make sure the kids college fund is
on track and at seven years old you got
plenty of time and you've been doing
really good with money so I think you're
not going to have any trouble but if you
need to put a hundred bucks a month
aside to get there or 150 bucks a month
aside to get there you can do that it's
real easy to do and kids college is
under way 15% going into retirement is
under way that's baby steps four and
five baby step six is then any extra
money we can lay our hands on that we
don't have to have for something else to
avoid debt then we use it on the house
and we just start throwing money at the
house as fast as we can the average
person doing this it drew is paying off
their home in about seven years and with
the numbers you gave me that wouldn't be
that far off and the fact that you've
already been very frugal and disciplined
and careful with your money to start
with again you've done a really fine job
so far sir I'm just giving you some
details and just kind of giving you a
little tune-up here which is kind of
what you were asking for all right yes
so the 15 let's say we took
thirty thousand let's say we took five
thousand and put that in the kids
account over here to boost that and get
it going into a 529 for kids college
that would leave us about ten thousand
dollars to do something else with if
you've got a purchase or a trip or
something in the offing you're going to
need that money for you need to earmark
it for that like if your cars are worn
out and it's time to move up you're
thinking next year I got to move up in
car then we're going to set that of the
ten aside like for car move up fund or
something okay if there's absolutely
nothing you need that money for you toss
it at the house using the program we're
talking about but we'll set some aside
for the kids some for the emergency fund
and then if you've got something else
fine if not we'll toss it towards the
house baby steps six and then once the
house is paid off there's nothing left
to do but crank up all of your investing
and your giving even higher and become
very very wealthy which is baby step
seven build wealth and give outrageously
and you're going to do all of that
you're right on track holder you 28 very
cool man you're doing great you really
are hold on I'll have a Zack pick up
he's filling in for Kelly today and
he'll get you a copy of the Total Money
Makeover mailed out and it'll show you
exactly what I'm talking about you can
walk through it with your wife and it
completely will work for you dude
you really are doing great you're
already running about 80 miles an hour
we're just going to crank you up to
about 120 right here and you're going to
really just polish this thing ups all
you're doing you're really doing good
work this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
you guys Rachel Cruz here hope you are
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better than the Dave Ramsey channel
don't tell them I said that I'm kidding
I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you